first of all I could just see when I
opened the text that it was just like
coming through multiple texts and the
first thing said Rory I'm going to be
brutally honest
what's the difference between a great
story and a mediocre story
uh the way it's told is the difference
between a great story and a mediocre
story everyone has a story everybody
everybody has a story like people that
you think maybe
are inherently boring well like why why
are they that way for instance
I don't know did you see the movie
everything everywhere like the Jamie Lee
Curtis character she's an accountant and
on the surface incredibly boring but
becomes very interesting so it's all
about how you tell the story and I I'd
heard a criticism of myself once saying
like he doesn't have a directing style
and
uh to me I try to whatever is Services
the story best I'm willing to do so in
my documentaries I've had animation I've
had Recreations I've had narration I've
had no narration I've had verite
um I've had anything you can do I'm
willing to do because I think every
story is different uh for the History
Channel film I mentioned that we were
gonna do Recreations and right away like
red flags at History Channel they're
thinking it's like The E True Hollywood
Story Recreations and I'm saying no
they're going to be abstract they're
going to be shot really well so I
actually did a test to show them we went
out and just did it for like one act of
the the movie it was a two-hour movie
and just to show them what it'd be like
and then it kind of put them at ease of
how this was going to be so
I don't think there's any mediocre
stories just mediocre storytellers
when someone gave you that note did they
do it to you directly or did they did
you hear it secondhand from someone no
they do it directly yeah they're very
direct and
um
you know one thing that I try to do too
in my relationships with people or
clients but also in the way I tell
stories is using humor because humor
diffuses uh tension quite a bit it also
brings people's defenses down so when
some so I find like you know if I can
joke and and keep things light it's
usually good and if you can do that uh
in
your documentary your film too they say
you make them laugh and you make them
cry so if you can make people laugh like
for instance in the Nature Boy
documentary about Ric Flair a lot of
funny moments in it funny stories funny
animation and I think it really brings
people's defenses down so that when you
learn about his son passing away from a
drug overdose it really hits you in the
gut and and I like doing things that
don't necessarily
spell out exactly what you should think
or feel it's to me it should be like
music it can be interpreted in many
different ways and so I don't want to
say like hey this person's bad and you
should feel that they're bad it should
be like you know
here's what they did and here's the plus
here's the minds and what do you take
away from it so
um
in regards to notes which I think was
your question
um
yes I try to be direct and I try to also
like be open
it's there is a bad quality that maybe
exists more in Hollywood of like passive
aggressiveness where people like it's
great and then like you leave the room
like oh that's terrible like just tell
me it's terrible for instance with my
first uh scripted movie Grace Point
I got I sent the first rough cut to Rob
Lowe
who just asked to see it his son's in it
plus he's just a very intelligent guy
very seasoned smart
and I got a text back first of all I
could just see when I opened the text
that it was just like coming through
multiple texts and the first thing said
Rory I'm going to be brutally honest and
when someone says the saying I'm going
to be brutally honest it's never like
something positive comes after it's not
Rory I'm going to be brutally honest
you're a genius it's so he was going to
be brutally honest that he thinks the
movie sucks and all the reasons why now
he didn't say that but he he laid it out
and that's one of the things I
appreciate about him is he's direct he
he didn't say yeah the movie's great and
then like talks trash about me or
something so I took his notes to heart
after I was a little upset gave myself
like a day to be upset about it and then
decided uh you know I was gonna try to
listen this guy maybe he knows what he's
doing at first I read him I'm like oh
what an idiot but now then I was like
wait a second this guy's done a lot more
than you have
um and I'm glad I listened I'm glad that
I took his notes to Heart
and that is much more what I would want
if as long as I can respect the person
you know that we're going in it with the
same plan to make something good now
sometimes you can be on a totally
different page with someone and their
motivation is not even to make something
good
I did a show
with Shaq Shaquille O'Neal
and I got the impression the network
maybe wanted more of like a reality show
like uh Keeping Up with the Kardashians
kind of like scripting scenes Well Jack
didn't want to do that in fact he wanted
to do it more like a documentary so now
you're having two different worlds kind
of colliding here somebody wants like
The Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
other person wants to do more of a
verite documentary we kind of met in the
middle a little
um but there you you are having some
diametrically opposed views but most of
the time
they just want something good you know
and you want something good and a lot of
it's subjective this is one thing I do
tell
friends and other filmmakers show
Runners you get one battle to fight
usually one so pick your battle
everything else if you want to keep
working with these people you're gonna
have to compromise on but there should
be one thing that you're like I'm not
compromising on this and and and 99 of
the time they'll let you have it because
they appreciate you doing the rest
well you said earlier about how you
don't mind friendships and work blending
because it's a good idea to work with
people that you like and that people
that you like will tell you the truth I
think it's important too when people
that you don't like will definitely tell
you the truth how they deliver it is is
also different you know well a lot of
times it's not not what you say but how
you say it I mean think about
people who yell at somebody you know
it's not what the information is but
it's how it's being delivered
so I tried to be very sensitive about
that on my film set I I watched these
videos on this fantastic YouTube channel
film courage and they tell people who
have been through the trenches and
it's important to see what what to do
what not to do and I wanted to have a
very good atmosphere like that was very
important for me on my film like a very
good set environment people are having a
good time not not like a good time like
they're partying or anything but that
they just feel there's like a lightness
to it that we're all in this together
and I learned that actors are different
like I had never really worked with
actors in this type of environment
before I've worked with him as like a
narrator but this was way different and
I learned different actors different
different situations and how they want
to be treated I had one actor Sean
Carrigan
uh excellent actor been in a lot of
things he's a former boxer so he likes
to be like you tell tell me what to do
coach I'll do it hey Sean can you cry
cry doing it let's do it boom tear he's
just like whatever you need angry he'll
do angry sad whatever he just wants to
be pleasing to the director who in his
mind is like a coach another actor on
the movie this guy Jim parrick
incredible actor I don't think I fully
appreciated how good of an actor until I
actually saw him on the big screen his
presence everything I mean uh a big guy
six like five intimidating you know I'm
kind of short myself I can walk under
most kitchen tables I'm a little I'm a
little guy I'm like five six so on a
good day I'm five six so automatically
I'm like looking up at him while we're
talking and he as an actor will not do
anything
anything unless he feels his character
is motivated to do it hey you're you're
supposed to take a drink here well I'm
not thirsty but it's written here you
take a drink I'm not thirsty so right
away this can be like could be a
nightmare for some directors he told me
his favorite actor was Robert Duvall and
I said why why Robert Dubai and
apparently Robert Duvall said he wants a
director to just shut up and leave him
alone and I guess Francis Ford Coppola
did that for him so I was like hmm okay
good notes to have here so uh we have
the scene one of my favorite scenes in
the movie where Jim parrick's character
cutter
is by a lake and he's remembering
something very personal and we shot this
at the magic hour when the sun's setting
it couldn't look more beautiful and
he has to do this kind of emotional
thing and he said he said Rory you get
you're getting one take out of this so
make sure you get my master in it now
it's an independent film we're shooting
with one camera on prime lenses and I
wanted to do two shots you know I don't
want to just do one shot and I and my DP
and I had this other shot besides the
close-up where we see cutter and then we
see jono and Lowe's character in the
background kind of defocus watching him
and I love that shot so I said to my DP
let's start with that shot my dp's like
are you sure you just said and I go
really want to do that shot and he goes
yeah me too so I said let's start with
that so we do that shot and it's great
Jim parrick tear down the cheek it's
awesome but I still need to do his
close-up
so I'm like well how do I handle this
you know should I say I'm the boss you
better do it I'm the boss well that's
not gonna work with this guy
that's gonna be a bad scene so
um I pull them aside privately privately
off to like a tree off in the woods
where we were filming and he's like he's
like how was that was that good gives me
a fist bump
like that was awesome man
now I said to him
I think I screwed something up there
look you were so incredible and I'm
really worried that I didn't get it and
it's a hundred percent my fault that it
happened this way
and is there any way like I know
you are empathetic to this um Can can
you be empathetic to me give me one more
take because I'm worried that I'm gonna
get back in the edit and not have what
we need and I I don't know what to say I
just messed up and he looks at me he's
like we got it don't worry don't worry
he like kind of Pats me on the back so
he does it motivated him through pure
pity on me and uh he even did a better
take that time he get a tear tear and I
told him that story at the premiere and
he was like you SOB but you know he was
like I was good so it's just like how do
you get what you need it's not
necessarily like how you do it but do
you get the result that you want so
hopefully that's a good example